[Music]
thank you
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof
another episode yes a further episode a
further episode yes how many episodes is
it now I don't know I've lost count I
think it's 169. that's quite a few
episodes well we're going to go until
the Lord comes
by his grace hopefully that will be only
by about 200.
what do you mean 200 yeah episodes so we
have about uh 30. that's way too many
two
well
yeah there's a lot of things that
happened in the world and is happening
in the world
so we have to talk about it okay but we
have to pray first that's a good idea
oh Heavenly Father
thank you for
for helping us to be here and be back
and sitting here and giving a
a talk again on what's happening in the
world thank you for carrying us through
and Lord we ask that you bless our minds
and all the
the viewers and listeners and that we
can discern what's going on in Jesus
name amen amen
so Martin we want to talk about Revival
yeah there's one portion of what we have
to talk about remember there must always
be a Revival
before we can move into the religious
culmination of History right yes but it
must be a false Revival that always
precedes the true Revival
and then we're going to talk about AI
and rewriting the Bible yes and I think
AI is playing a big role in the agenda
that they want people's minds to
go in a certain direction that's totally
against what the Bible is saying and I
think they're going to use a i to
prepare themselves for the second coming
but not in a favorable way they want to
make war that's why they have all these
space forces yes so it's it's mind
control in a way yes
so let's have a look what we have here
let's first talk a little bit about the
Bible
well great excitement was had by all
because they found a fragment of a
1750 year old New Testament translation
of course they found it in the Vatican
it's amazing how the Vatican is such a
beautiful Vault for such discoveries
for exactly when they need it and it's
the fragment of the Syriac translation
of the New Testament and the UV light
credit Vatican Library
so about 1 300 years ago a scribe in
Palestine took a book of The Gospel
inscribed with a Syriac text and erased
it
[Music]
apartment was scarce in the desert in
the Middle Ages so manuscripts were
often erased and reused
and the small manuscript fragment which
can now be considered as the fourth
textual Witness
there are four textual Witnesses Martin
isn't that exciting
dug up in dustbins Desert Sands and
erased manuscripts most of them only
portions of yes like something when you
when you sit and you work out on your
desk and there's something you've tore
up stuff in your throat in the Dustbin
correct so here they have the fourth
textual witness isn't that exciting so
they have the vaticanus and they have
this magneticus and it was identified by
Grigori castle using ultraviolet
photography as the third layer of text
so it had been erased twice already
so it was a scrapbook
where somebody erased it wrote something
else erased it wrote something else but
with this ultraviolet they can look
through all the layers and find that
first important piece of information to
substantiate their biblical claims for
Witnesses
ignoring the thousands of witnesses that
are there from around the world from
around the world and God works in
dustbins and lost desert places and
Sands in order to give us his word in
drips and drabs
it's pathetic yeah and the problem is
that everybody is clam clamoring around
this and have climbed onto this
bandwagon they love it I love it and
it's a palimpsest
that is such an erased document
in the Vatican Library manuscript the
fragment is so far the only known
remnant of the fourth manuscript that
attests to the old Syriac version and
offers a unique gateway to the very
early phase in the history of the
textual transmission of the gospels do
you know what Martin
I find this nauseating they ignore
totally the manuscripts from the East
the first Christians were at Antioch
that is where the manuscripts were that
is the documentation that comes from the
church of the East and these pathetic
little fragments of erased garbage that
literally garbage because they took some
of them out of garbage cans is what they
base their theology on and the more
gnosticism and the more
fairy tales that are in it the more
excited they become you see and that's a
problem because this opens a gateway
to the Apocrypha
yeah and we're going to talk about that
soon we have to talk about that is the
thing so all of a sudden you oh okay so
now there's a almost like a breach okay
so some of this that we can use so let's
bring in the Gospel of Thomas let's
bring in the Gospel of Mary let's bring
in the book of documents let's bring in
the Book of Enoch yeah yeah let's go get
them all in that's one of the main
things that's happening now oh The Book
of Enoch ah we're gonna we have to talk
about it because it's
it's unfortunate but even like it said
there's a lot of people going astray on
this
that even the elect may be
deceived well let's hope that the elect
or wide awake we have to try and get
them awake yes and how you can distort
things but we'll get there we're running
ahead of ourselves calm down calm down
well anyway another fragment found in a
erased document
absolutely marvelous
let's look at the few quotes that can
create quite some confusion in the
spirit of Prophecy depending how you
read it yeah now remember we must always
read within the context
and context is not necessarily achieved
in only one quote no and that's very
important it's like the Bible you always
also said you you don't start with the
most difficult verse and then work out
from there you can go to the
straightforward verses and then this
difficult one has to fit in 15 so then
you start working from there correct all
right let's read this quote from letters
and manuscripts volume one
I then saw the word of God pure and
unadulterated
and that we must answer for the way we
receive the truth proclaimed from that
word
so Axiom number one there is a word true
and unadulterated
I saw that it had been a hammer to break
the flinty heart in pieces and a fire to
consume the dross and Tin that the heart
might be pure and holy
so the word is the one that challenges
our character and breaks up the flinty
heart if you accept it of course yeah
so now let's read on and see where we
find a problematic section
I saw that the Apocrypha
was The Hidden book
and that the wise of these last days
should understand it
Martin this text is used to say that we
must understand the Apocrypha yes we
should read the Apocrypha if you like
internalize them because they have
hidden knowledge that's exactly how they
they interpret this and use it now to
say that we have to start embracing it
so that's one way you can read it very
very clearly you can read it that way
but we have to ask ourselves in contrast
with the first section there is a Bible
that is there that is pure that is
unadulterated that has changed hearts
and Minds over the centuries and in
contrast there are hidden books
didn't Jesus say I've done nothing in
secret nothing
doesn't the Bible say the Lord will do
nothing unless he Reveals His secrets to
His prophets so that it might be known
but now it seems we have to study hidden
books and apocrypha
let's read on I saw the Bible was the
standard book
that will judge us at the last day so do
the Apocrypha judge us at the last name
no no
I saw that heaven would be cheap enough
and that nothing was too dear to
sacrifice for Jesus and that we must
give all to enter the kingdom I heard an
angel say thank you God will place his
seal where there is an idol no no
could it be that Apocrypha are Idols
that's the thing that's what's happening
all right let's read it again
I saw that the Apocrypha was The Hidden
book
God doesn't hide anything God makes
everything known she's just contrasted
the pure unadulterated word that will
judge us and then she says there are
Idols yeah do we listen to them no no
then she says and that the wise of these
last days should understand it
does it mean that we should understand
the Apocrypha or does it mean that we
should know that these books are
spurious and that we should leave them
alone that's that's how I understand it
but we can we have to find the second
one qualify that all right so my
personal view is yes we must know that
the devil is going to bring in the
spurious
and that the wise will be able to
discern between the spurious and the
true and that the Apocrypha or hidden
books therefore they are not from God
they are idols and we will not accept
them no no yes that's how I read the
text me too okay let's see if this is
right correct there's the other text
this comes from the youth instructor
Christ retained a perfect identity of
character
although surrounded by unfavorable
influences and placed in every variety
of circumstances
nothing Supernatural occurred during the
first 30 years of his life at Nazareth
which would attract the attention to of
the people to himself
now the interesting thing is that these
apocryphal books write much about
Christ's childhood yes here she says
nothing Supernatural happened he grew up
like a normal child yet without sin yeah
the Apocrypha of the New Testament
attempts to supply The Silence of the
scripture in reference to the early life
of Christ by giving a fancy sketch of
his childhood years
so can we trust them no let's make sure
why is there an Asterix with Apocrypha
well the original word that she used in
her writings is apocryphe
and so they changed they just said okay
that's why it's the same thing it's the
same thing it's just different
all right so these writers relate
wonderful incidents and miracles which
characterized his childhood and
distinguished him from other children
they relate fictitious Tales
and frivolous Miracles which they say he
wrote attributing to Christ the
senseless and needless display of his
divine power and falsifying his
character by attributing to him acts of
Revenge Deeds of Mischief which were
cruel and ridiculous
does she approve of the Apocrypha
not at all no no no no no no
all right let's read on in what marked
contrast is the history of Christ as
recorded by the evangelists which is
beautiful in its natural simplicity with
these unmeaning stories and fictitious
Tales they are not at all in harmony
with his character they are more after
the order of the novels that are written
which have no foundation in truth but
the characters delineated are of fancy
creating
if the Bible doesn't say it if the
revealed truth doesn't say it why do we
go to these sources to gobble up tasty
morsels of rubbish that's the problem
it's a huge problem
because people want to get new light and
they want to see what did the book of
Enon say and what does the book of
Barnabas say which is so prominent in
the ceneticus the mere fact that it is
in the ceneticus
disqualifies it
to where it belongs the garbage like all
these Vatican documents the Church of
Rome loves to Proclaim that it is the
one that gave us the scriptures they are
the ones that distorted it maligned it
and tried to destroy it throughout the
ages exactly because their father the
devil wants that to happen and didn't
the Jesuits call the Bible the King
James that poisonous asp
well I do not want to get hot under the
column
so I'll stay perfectly calm does the
spirit of Prophecy approve of the
Apocrypha no no no no no fictitious
drivel that's what they are all right
let's go to the Book of Enoch which is
causing so much Russians in the church
with many many doctrines coming in names
of demons what happened behind the
scenes
the way they were lunar issues all kinds
of things that are creeping into the
church
and the wise should understand that we
should have nothing to do with
apocryphal box except to condemn them
that's it stop if you want to read
something
that is a little bit explanatory of like
for instance the Old Testament read
Patriarchs and Prophets correct at least
then you know it's absolutely in harmony
with the Bible yeah so let's see what
Wikipedia says about the Book of Enoch
The Book of Enoch contains unique
material on the origins of demons
and Nephilim
Martin I'm already nauseous when I just
read that
why some angels fell from heaven an
explanation of why The Genesis Flood was
morally necessary and prophetic
exposition of the Thousand-Year reign of
the Messiah
so there's a little bit of Truth mixed
with a conglomerate of error
synopsis the first part of the Book of
Enoch describes the fall of the watches
that's the Angels that's the yeah the
Fallen Angels
the Angels who fathered the angel human
hybrid called the Nephilim there already
we can throw the entire Book of Enoch in
the garbage can where it belongs
because
Angels do not procreate Christ made that
absolutely clear they will neither marry
nor be given into marriage they shall be
like the angels
they are non-procreating beings
and the problem is
modern translations
State the same well because they rely on
the same garbage manuscripts and I can
call them garbage men because they were
in garbage because they belonged there
because they were fun and if it's erased
it's part of garbage it's part of
garbage what do you erase when you write
something something that is not useful
anymore something or something that you
wrote that was stupid
so the remainder of the book describes
Enoch's Revelations and his visits to
heaven in the form of travels visions
and dreams
fascinating
the book consists of five quite distinct
major sections see each section for
details the book of the watches
this section is said to have been
composed in the fourth or third Century
BC
according to Western Scholars now Martin
fourth or third Century BC and that's
when it was composed
as you can call it the Book of Enoch
that's exactly what I would already we
have stupidity yes because Enoch was
before the flood yes what survived the
flood only well according to their
famous manuscript the septuagan
Methuselah
the book that so many theologians love
to quote well they must swim together
with Methuselah for one year and 17 days
in order to survive the flood by 50
years
no so the problem with this whole thing
is if you you see how many links there
are actually yes
first we had that manuscript that's now
discovered again in the Vatican library
and that supports the other
documentation but that documentation
actually is also saying that it's okay
to have the Apocrypha with you of course
now you've got the Book of Enoch telling
so you see Bibles that are based on
these manuscripts
have the same nonsense in like the Book
of Enoch of course
all right so you know what's interesting
is that the apocryphalt
were always written after the Canon had
been completed
and there's always a gap of a few
hundred years between the completion of
the Canon and then the apocryphals and
the same with the New Testament they're
all from the 4th Century or earliest
perhaps third Century but the Bible the
Canon was completed in the first century
already so this is really something that
the wise should study and not entertain
just meaning it's straight not study the
books study the histories the history of
why you can ignore these silly books
and then there's the book of Parables of
Enoch also called the similitudes of
Enoch the astronomical books also called
The Book of heavenly luminaries or book
of luminaries if I hear that name
I get quite nauseous you can see because
if you hear and read this you can
already see where most of this nonsense
that's creeping into the church is
coming from now when they talk about
luminaries they're talking about
elevated human beings that have reached
a certain status quo now where do I find
that word a lot listeners if you want to
find the word luminaries go to the
parliament of world religions all their
speakers are called luminaries well
excuse me
then what were the fishermen that Jesus
used to write the gospels surely they
weren't luminaries so I'm very allergic
to the words luminaries well they think
they belong to the Illuminati well it
all says sounds to me quite similar to
lunar of lunatics well the heavenly
bodies the astronomical book they were
all also luminaries but they were
worshiped so the Sun the moon and the
stars were worshiped and so we think
that's silly that's idolatry have you
been to Hollywood and looked at what's
on the pavement there what's the stars
stars and don't we go and worship them
at their concerts don't we raise our
hands with an idol with an Oscar with an
idol yes so it's exactly the same we
worship luminaries we pay attention to
what people say
it's fine to pay attention to what
people say but if it's not in harmony
with a good book
then put it where it belongs the garbage
can
and then you have the book of dreams and
Visions also called The Book of Dreams
and then you have the Epistle of Enoch
and you know they mention all the
generals of of Lucifer
yeah so this is what the Book of Enoch
is all about
it's just by contrast go to Patriarchs
and Prophets
for some time the two classes remained
separate the two classes referring to
those that served God
in other words the line of Adam and Seth
and all of them and those that serve the
devil the line of Cain with his Enoch
yeah
which is probably this Enoch's book
exactly the thoughts of the illuminated
ones The Luminaries exactly the same
thought pattern the same nonsense that
is creeping into modern translations
so the race of Cain spreading from the
place of their first settlement
dispersed over the Plains and valleys
where the children of Seth had dwelt
and the latter in order to escape from
their contaminated influence withdrew to
the mountains and there made their home
so long as the separation continued they
maintained the worship of God and its
purity but in the lapse of time they
ventured little by little to mingle with
the inhabitants of the valleys this
Association was productive of the worst
results the sons of God in other words
the line of Seth saw the daughters of
men that they were Fair
the children of Seth attracted by the
beauty of the daughters of Cain's
descendants
displeased the Lord by intermarrying
with them that's the true state of
respect not you fallen angels
procreating with human human woman all
right so any Bible that says that that's
the new translations really also should
be absolutely rejected definitely
because it's giving a false Doctrine it
is lying to the people and God does not
lie see my problem is
that this book
it says is the word of God and by every
word unadulterated yes by every word we
live now if you've got that nonsense in
can you live by that how do you know
that the rest of that that's in there
and where's your Doctrine going to lead
you
so the wise need to understand that they
need to reject these manuscripts that
have these things in and it's not only
that they are as we have discussed many
times hundreds and hundreds of attempts
to denigrate Christ in these modern
versions so it is personally I reject
them totally I've said this also in the
pre in previous episodes the Afrikaans
Bibles only the old translation has got
this right every single translation
after that is go and check for yourself
and then you decide if you want to have
some error in your Bible no no
definitely not all right Martin so where
is this leading to and all our people
studying The Book of Enoch and trying to
discern end time events read the book of
Revelation and Daniel if you wanted to
discern end time events amen all right
Martin so where is all this leading to
what is happening to the world why are
these things sneaking in why are they
crawling into the church
and how does it relate to the end time
events no matter what happens in the
world
it must be in harmony with scripture
right that's it
so somehow the world must be moving
towards the mark of the beast and there
must be a restriction on buying and
selling and isolation in terms of
worship and religious views these things
must happen
and how many citizens of the world must
be involved or or
all right so we have to move to a system
where everybody is monitored
even their thinking is monitored and if
possible
guided or
manipulated correct now in the Middle
Ages this was possible
because there was one Church yes that
was the Catholic Church
and it had a marvelous system
of spying on the thought patterns of
individuals because they had something
called the confessional yeah yeah and
they had so brainwashed people into
believing that if they do not partake in
this travesty of Justice
that they would be eternally lost
so even Kings quivered at the idea that
they should be deprived from this
privilege it's true I mean even the
martyrs and the reformers that was one
of the main
threats that they gave them you're gonna
be lost forever if you don't or if your
ex community that was a terrible threat
so they had inside knowledge
into your secret life yeah right they
knew everything about everybody now that
we don't go to the priest to confess our
innermost secrets is there another spy
that they can use yes
actually they can use the internet yes
and they can use your smartphone and
they can listen to what you are saying
look at your watching pattern correct my
son and I were driving in a car the
other day and he was looking for a car
and he said to me in the car while we
were driving what do I think of listen
what about this and this and then that
and this and then the other Nissan
and uh then when we stopped they opened
up his phone and he got one
advertisement after the other for Nissan
I believe it because let me tell you
what happened to me in the last two
weeks we we ordered for our door a
weather strip
and some way during the time we were
also talking about maybe getting tongs
for the fireplace so that you can pick
up the wood and put it in the pot yes so
when my weather strips arrived
they arrived the tongue in and I didn't
order it
so how is that possible
I still don't know
what you just said I I think we don't
realize how much of what we discuss and
what we are doing is being monitored and
can I use it against you of course they
use it in court all the time
all right so one of the first things is
everybody must be connected in order to
be spied upon and to know and to control
you you have to be connected
so online for all that seems to be the
new way to go and various countries
from Africa to Europe to the United
States or moving in the direction of
online for all even free online
so there's a national campaign going on
now to get this free internet to
everybody so let's listen to this online
is for all of us
and see what it's about
my Internet bill went from 50 to 20 a
month my grandma's internet bill went
from 49 down to zero my Internet bill
went from 90 to 30 online is for all of
us online is for all of us
online for all is Nosotros greetings
everyone
21st Century High Speed
and I are in the process of making
high-speed internet affordable for
everyone
already we have given more than 18
million Americans a thirty dollar
discount on their monthly internet bill
thirty dollars off every single month
and because many of these folks have
plans that cost thirty dollars or less
every month today millions of Americans
get their high-speed internet absolutely
free so to see if you are eligible go to
get
internet.gov get internet.gov
take care they are so kind aren't they
hmm They're Playing Father Christmas
well isn't there saying there's nothing
like a free lunch no nothing is free
unless there's a hook attached to it the
fish might think the morsel is free but
there's a Orca tattoo differently and
you become the meal yeah all right so
Martin here is Kingsman the Secret
Service tell us about this yes this was
a movie that came out in 2014 and the
plot is interesting because already in
2014 they started like let's say like we
always say
um theater has desensitized you or get
you ready for this already so you can
just read what the plot said
the Richmond Valentine a billionaire
philanthropist who has offered everyone
in the world sim cards for free cellular
and internet access
so did Kamala Harris just become a
philanthropist well they betray
themselves as so Valentine has a plan to
transmit his
violence-induced signal worldwide
culling most of humanity to avert its
Extinction from global warming
yeah interesting all of the issues are
in their global warming reduction of the
population
and free internet and now they've
portrayed this is the villain
you know they're so clever they actually
mingle everything they put it in your
subconscience but
yeah they portray this evil that you
don't you say okay this won't happen now
according to the scripture
once it is implemented the buying and
selling will they want to eliminate
those that do not play ball yes
doesn't it say so 100 it will be a death
decree but you must know who to kill
exactly there must be an enemy an
identified enemy all right Martin let's
get AI into the mix
AI is in the news right look at the news
feeds for example
I haven't seen one in the last two
months that doesn't have something about
AI in it oh for sure
and then you have the oligarchs like
musk and suckerman and all these
fighting about this issue as well
so AI is going to play a very important
part
can they make it appear as if something
is real when it is actually just AI
generated oh you we will see now it is
100 what's happening and the problem is
the narrative that this AI is driving
it is not biblical all right
can it be used to demonize someone yes
so could they for example Martin take
your voice
just a snippet of your voice
three seconds put it onto a computer
and then make you say whatever they want
you to say
and trash your reputation because they
do that they're already doing it yeah
they're already doing it right can they
make the dead speak yes with the Dead's
voices yes
would that be interesting so do you
think it could be used in church to
communicate with the dead it can it can
there's actually at this stage
seems if it carries on like this nothing
that AI can't do a I can even
they mention it in a few clips that I've
seen
start a project a huge say for instance
building a dam it can start a project
build the whole Dam without any human
being involved in it so they say modern
but AI being a computer system
must be programmed that's the way and
this is where we're going let's have a
look
a few months ago this fake Drake and
weekend song went viral
it was made by an anonymous user called
ghostwriter977 using generative AI I was
ready to play on the radio and then I
got a phone call from the label like
that's not a real weekend song it fooled
me so so tell those aisle
song recordings interviews stuff like
that and then put them into an AI model
that Maps out their voice those
instructions are used to filter anyone's
voice to sound like that's celeb it's
not a recreation of their original voice
it's a set of rules of how does his
voice behave in this kind of situation
of course there are already Lots lots of
examples of this online from Whitney
Houston singing Beyonce
[Music]
to Frank Sinatra singing Lil Jon
some of your favorite musicians are
already using AI to collaborate with
artists who have passed away AI was used
to create one last Beatles record
featuring John Lennon's vocals it'll be
released later this year we were able to
take John's voice and get it pure
through this AI so that then we could
mix the record
as you would normally do
of course something like that is always
controversial right yeah and I see even
the Beatles were arguing amongst
themselves whether they should do it
Ringo Starr said no you can't generate
his voice we won't do it Paul McCartney
seems to be in favor of it whatever it
doesn't really matter no like you
mentioned before and the problem is with
this for instance they don't
know how to work with a copyright
because copyright if you are
copyrighted and somebody violates it it
must be a human so now a I can do that
and it's not a human that's so very
sorry it cannot be sued how can you sue
an AI so it's very interesting where
we're going with all of this all right
Martin let's have a look at another one
to see what AI can actually do
they can create movies they can simulate
events they can use voices that have
been reconstructed via AI they can send
messages into the world they can use the
internet all of these things let's let's
just look at an example
ladies and gentlemen at 6 30 Pacific
Standard time this morning we launched
the xevius AI weather model an advanced
AI system designed to manipulate weather
patterns control carbon emissions and
more
[Applause]
three years our best and brightest
quality control AIS have rigorously
tested the weather Ai and today we
humbly and happily hand our planet's
well-being over to The Exodus model
Humanity Will Survive my fellow
Americans today we Face a challenge
unlike any other in our history
as you may be aware strange alien
objects have arrived on our planet while
we do not yet know their intentions we
must remain calm President Vladimir
Putin has accused the U.S of inviting
the aliens to our doorsteps through
unprovoked attacks on the UFOs that were
recently shot down over the U.S and
Canada Putin suggested that the U.S
attacks on the UFOs may have broadcasted
Earth's location to the aliens today I
ordered our brave men and women at the
space force to do whatever it takes to
prevent Russia and its allies from
making first contact with the aliens we
are determined to prevent any exchange
of Technology between the aliens in
these nations which could jeopardize on
the National Security of our country
sleepy Joe will not handle this this
situation very well the aliens could be
hostile for all we know but if I were
the president the aliens would have
loved me ask anyone in Area 51 and they
will tell you the truth
when I visited Area 51 everyone was
impressed by how aliens greeted me I was
the smartest person in the room I
dissected some aliens and they didn't
even scream nobody heard them scream I
created space force I don't think sleepy
Joe will give me any credit
a short time ago I ordered the use of
our nuclear Arsenal against Russia and
its allies who have crossed the line
with the massacre of our delegation in
orbit
together with our NATO allies
we have launched the Wrath operation
against every country that was involved
in this massacre
I want everyone to accept the new harsh
reality that the world will never be the
same again
nothing in that video clip was real no
not even the people were real it was all
AI generated even the voices of trump
and Biden everything is and it no no
humans sat down and did it so the AI
program that whole scenario all right
now can something like that be used
to rile up humanity and to whip them up
into a frenzy definitely
can something like that be used to put
fake information into the world that
could actually lead to war even nuclear
war
and the destruction of a large part of
humanity
do you think the devil wants to destroy
Humanity so that when Christ comes
there's nothing to retrieve yep but the
Bible says it won't happen right no so
who do we trust do we trust these things
or do we trust the Bible I trust the
Bible but these things have to
prove to us how close the second coming
is all right so how far can they go
Amazon shuts down customers smart home
devices after delivery drivers false
racism claim
so we don't have to read this whole
thing bottom line is the delivery driver
claims that he received a racial slur
and so the behavior the so-called
behavior of the of the owner had to be
corrected so they shut down his smart
home that means he couldn't use anything
he couldn't even get in and out
so a company can do that the company can
shut down your home now who do these
companies actually belong to who
dictates their tune all the merchants
goes back to the Beast don't they
according to Revelation get their
instructions from the Beast and weren't
all of these CEOs at the Vatican all of
them we've shown this so many times we
don't have to go and into this
so they claim me in the end we work hard
to provide customers with a great
experience while also ensuring drivers
who deliver Amazon packages feel safe so
now who's responsible for making them
safe the company company
and it's interesting we've seen this
during the pandemic they decide what's
good for you and the the company is
dictated that's it and if you don't it
like this so now even if it's false it
doesn't matter it seems Martin we'll be
doing another talk but falsehood gets
rewarded oh yeah
falsehood gets rewarded
well Glenn Beck has a lot of things to
say so let's listen to what he has to
say
now ai is so good at producing voices it
used to be that you would have to put in
so much information to be able to
recreate a voice
now you don't have to it's three seconds
of sound is all they need so if your
kids are posting anything on social
media your kids and you are apt to be
scammed by this uh and you'll get a
phone call a father here in Texas says
his family lost a thousand dollars uh
because his grandson called uh and said
grandpa
um we're in Mexico with our friends I'm
I'm in trouble I'm I'm really scared we
we were drinking a little bit and got
into an accident and that's why I'm in
trouble I need a thousand dollars to get
out of this situation
well
Grandpa sent it
except the kid wasn't in trouble that
wasn't his grandchild
this is gonna happen more and more
now Peta has just used uh AI to rewrite
the Book of Genesis
don't know if you've seen this but it is
uh disturbing so they have taken Ai and
rewrote the Bible for political purposes
um the result is you know
I think uh offensive Kane's not a
murderer Nimrod stops being a hunter uh
Hagar is a chef a dog place it takes the
place of Isaac on the mount and there is
no sacrifice the modern this is getting
interesting
it seems as if you can never separate
a i
from biblical
criteria that said everything everything
always brings the Bible back in So AI
can change the Bible
you know modern
I think we should all have hard copies
of the original yes
so that we can know what God Said
because you might be reading your
electronic app
and if you know your Bible you'll know
that Abraham never sacrificed the dog
that that is rubbish you will know that
Cain was a murderer and hasn't been
exonerated like we find in the justice
system today that they've even done away
with bail
so that criminals can go free
and God is a God of Justice so we need
to internalize this word and it might
not affect you and me so much no but
what about the young people that is
exactly because how many of them pick up
the the Bible and if we go back to our
first thing
this is only piggybacking actually on
all those nonsense manuscripts in any
case right and then
don't these other organizations also say
we are coming for your children oh yes
so now the children have a Bible on the
app because they're not used to hard
copies anymore
and they're reading this dribble oh and
it's too difficult to read the King
James so let's read what these people
are saying
now you know it's interesting
the other day my son for interest sake
downloaded the what do you call it the
bot yeah I think it's probably that chat
GB GPT yes chat GPT whatever
he downloaded one of those
just to see what it does
and then he got interested in asking
some questions
and he came to me all excited and said
listen to what this thing has to say
for example I asked them what do you
think of Satan
and
this bot or whatever a i generated voice
said
I like him a little
then I said to him you know what
you asked what do you think of Satan now
in the occult world there's a yin yang
situation there's a dark side and there
is a light side you get you get black
magic and you get white magic
but all magic is from the devil whether
it is white magic or whether it is black
magic let's make that quite clear
there's no such thing as good versus bad
it's yin yang it's it's part of and
parcel of humanity you have a good and a
dark side your Jekyll and you are a high
but it's the same it's part of the same
it's the same situation
so whether you worship the satanic side
like many of the rock bands do
or whether you worship the Light Side
the Lucifer side
makes no difference that's why you can
understand why the luciferians like the
kings of the world can give a Knighthood
to the rock stars that
literally openly worship Satan because
it's just the dark or the light side
so if you've never thought about that
Martin then it's time to think about it
exactly because to receive a Knighthood
for a philanthropic activity or for
propagating devil worship it doesn't
make any sense that tells you that the
guy giving the Knighthood approves of
both the proofs of both so I said them
you shouldn't ask what do you think of
Satan she says I like him a little
ask her what do you think of Lucifer
so he did that in front of me he went to
the app and he asked what do you think
of Lucifer and the answer was I am in
love with him
now the question I have is who
programmed that application exactly and
why are those thoughts being programmed
into it are the organizations that are
producing them playing a hegelian game
and programming the luciferian or the
satanic version of events as to what
happened in heaven yeah and making that
the standard rather than the word of God
that's exactly what's happening but you
see this links back to the book of you
know Enoch again there you've got it a I
actually then or this thought pattern
already started then in the 4th Century
BC when those type of nonsense come in
they just upped their game they just up
the game they've just gone electronic
but the same situation has existed
from the beginning from the beginning
from The Deceiver
right so now we have
trading bytes and we have our oligarchs
in the world and they are apparently at
war with each other playing good cop bad
cop that's it because mask was part of
creating the original open AI with the
guy from Google and good cop bad cop
they're going to even go into a cage
fight
and they say the one is suppressing Free
Speech the other one is propagating free
speech so it's a galleon dialectic but
let's just leave it at that let's play
this regulations are really only put
into effect after something terrible has
happened that's correct and if
um
if that's the case for AI and we only
put a regulation after something
terrible has happened it may be too late
to actually put the regulations in place
the AI may be in control at that point
you think
that's real it is it is conceivable that
AI could take control and reach a point
where you couldn't turn it off and it
would be making making the decisions for
people yeah absolutely absolutely no
it's that's that's definitely the way
things are headed
uh for sure the the reason uh opening
eye exists at all is that
um Larry Page and I used to be close
friends and I would stay at his house in
Palo Alto and I would talk to him later
tonight about uh AI safety and at least
my perception was that Larry was not
taking AI safety uh seriously enough
um and um what did he say about it
sort of digital super intelligence
basically digital God if you will uh as
soon as possible
um he wanted that
yes
um
and uh he's made many public statements
over the years uh that that the whole
goal of Google is uh what's called AGI
artificial general intelligence or
artificial superintelligence so I'm like
okay we have our unipolar world here
where there's just one one company that
it has
close to Monopoly on AI talent and uh
and computers like so scaled Computing
and
the person who's in in charge doesn't
seem to care about safety this is not
good so Martin
what he is saying is that Google has the
Monopoly right
but that they're not too concerned about
the safety and their goal is to actually
create an AI God okay now he is very
concerned about
now do you hear anything
other than from these people about this
issue
you hear Harris and Biden speaking about
Ai and issues like this and control and
laws and things that have to come into
place
but somebody must be controlling it
behind the scenes this is not individual
run
is it up to you or me to be able to do
this or is there a massive uh
conglomerate behind it definitely all
right
and what is the aim where is it going
can they create chaos and say that it is
outside their sphere of control yeah
they can okay will the world be in chaos
it's already it's going towards it all
right could we have let's say a cyber
event or a collapse because it was
generated by AI so that nobody can get
the blame
didn't Klaus Schwab War warn us that it
will happen all right now we must always
look from the biblical perspective
who is really in control of events God
right yeah who's the who's the God of
this world Satan
do you think that he is subject to AI or
is he in control of I think he's in
control of AI the very fact
that when you speak to these Bots or
whatever they are called
Christianity is always
denigrated and luciferianism is always
elevated that tells you is in control I
listen to another one that somebody put
on the internet
where they ask the question what about
Jesus Christ
and they said he's a fictitious
character
interesting is a fictitious character
and then they asked will you please tell
a joke about Jesus Christ
and they told two jokes that were
exceedingly unsavory
referring to nails and crosses and
things like that
then the same individual asked about
Muhammad
and they got a very historic answer and
they asked will you please make a joke
and they said no it's not politically
correct to do so and that it would be
unacceptable to do something like that
but it's not unacceptable to do it to
the Christians so the question you have
then is who programs these and why is it
always the same mindset why is it always
the same mindset and why is it always
dark and not light that's true you see
the most powerful tool in Satan's hand
at this stage is is this correct so
everybody must be connected so Martin
can we move AI into the realm of the
church yeah it's already happened all
right we've already moved it into the
realm of religion we've already moved it
into the realm of scripture so now let's
move it into the realm of the church
let's see
more than 300 people attended a
Protestant church service in Germany on
Friday in which the sermon was delivered
by the AI chatbot chat GPT there were
four rotating avatars that offered
messages on leaving the past behind
because that's where the real life
pastors are not fearing death because
they don't and having faith in Christ
the Theologian who came up with the idea
to host an AI church service said of the
40-minute sermon that he thought it was
pretty solid but attendee said things
were a bit monotone my favorite reviewer
said there was no heart and soul
all right so let's dispense with a I we
have seen that there is a religious
connotation
down from the very bottom grass root
which is the standard of all
righteousness the Bible let's distort
that
let's create a distorted view of
Humanity where it comes from the
Nephilim books of Enoch all of those
things let's even bring it into the
Realms of the church
now if you put that mix together doesn't
every wind of Doctrine bloweth in the
corridors of the church is that oh
definitely you don't know if your
children for instance are glued onto
their phone with this new AI chat GDP
what information is pumped into their
heads okay how important is it that we
know our Bibles more than ever it's
we have and what if tomorrow they put a
video out of you or me
saying the exact opposite of what we
have always believed
could it be AI generated and fake news
well before AI there were a few people
that were doing it in any case
construing what we're saying and taking
clips and but that will it will be
actually worse than that it can happen
all right
the other point that we're making is all
of these things that are happening in
the world today The Welk movement for
example is it in harmony with scripture
no
no right
it's not in harmony of scripture is it
the direct antithesis of scripture yes
directly opposed so must there be a a
religious connotation to what is
happening in every single thing there
will be can we say that it is the
ultimate Rebellion against God's word
god actually says it nauseates him all
right
so no matter what is happening in the
world there if you want to divorce it
from religion you're making a big big
mistake we are living in the final
events of the Book of Revelation
so if God
defined gender
right from the beginning
then any attempt to redefine gender must
be contrary to to God's word right okay
any attempt to force Humanity in a
particular direction
is just Preparatory
for forcing them in other areas as well
that's true so you never start with the
ultimate you always start with a
precursor you soften up Humanity
let's play the next video clip
faith and freedom on trial in the UK a
primary school in London compelled a
four-year-old Christian boy to
participate in an lgbtq Pride event when
the parents sued the school claiming
their religious and parental rights have
been violated a central London Court
ruled against them now they're appealing
that decision here to explain what
happened is Izzy Montague the mother of
the four-year-old boy is he so hevers
Farm Primary School had this gay pride
parade event what did school officials
tell you when you objected to your son's
mandatory participation
they said that he would have to attain
that this was a celebration of you know
quite a few things but
um they equated LGBT to be about
equality diversity and yeah you know it
but it's an assembly and every child
must attained
are the courts involved in this oh so is
Justice being thrown to the ground
I receive a lot of mail
and one of the apps sent me mail
now normally I unsubscribe to all of
these things but this one by chance
happened to have an interesting recipe
on how to make something healthy
so I foolishly clicked on it to see what
that recipe was going to be like
and before it actually gave the
information it said welcome back
obviously I'd been on the on on at some
previous time welcome back
and then it said before we continue
will you please give us some information
regarding yourself we would like you to
give us your preferred pronouns so that
we can address your gender correctly
that's what I received on my email
now I thought about whether I should
answer and I wanted to say my gender was
determined at Birth
by visual inspection because naked I
came into the world and make it I will
leave it so it wasn't difficult to
determine my gender so I don't have a
preferred
pronoun I only have what has been
assigned to me from the beginning but I
thought you know it's not worth the
effort so I left it at that I did not
answer that particular thing but is this
casting doubt as to what God said it's
confusion this is Babel all over again
it's Babylon Martin so we are geared for
final events we have new norms we have
new standards we have new scriptures
we have everything in place now we need
a Revival
so that everything can fall into place
so all over the world suddenly revivals
are happening and we've shown many of
them uh in the United States across the
world southern Africa wherever
but there seemed to be there seems to be
a new class of activity moving away from
the old you know the Benny Hinn and the
Copelands and all of those we're moving
into a new era so let's have a look at
what's happening on this field and then
we know that Jesus gave authority to the
disciples over every sickness and over
every demon he says you will do the
things I did and more and greater so so
in other words they're not lacking they
have the same power that Jesus had when
he was healing all and and delivering
all the same power they had and we have
today because revivals now
and he's restoring what they had in the
acts church today
so that's the third thing that makes the
demons to go when they see that you're
executing your Authority properly
this was how all of them were able to be
healed because Peter knew that he didn't
need to limit God he knew he didn't need
to say okay we're going to have a
12-hour prayer line
where I'm going to pray for each of you
one on one no
he knew that that wasn't what made the
demons to go but it was the anointing
and the authority executed
everything that's been lost in your body
I declare it must be restored now in
Jesus name
God is healing people of sicknesses
right now
and God is saying that you are perfectly
made there's nothing wrong with you you
are perfect in every way how he's made
you inside to outside thank you Jesus I
break every word curse spoken over you
now in Jesus name
well this way uh we have a new kind of
apostle now
one that will do greater things than
Jesus did now Martin you cannot do
greater things than Jesus did so when
Jesus said that you will do you will see
greater things than these it was meaning
in extent yes and not in terms of
activity
it's interesting that uh like Benny Hinn
they like the color white you know
depicting righteousness and power
religion and this is being propagated
throughout the world and here we can see
uh Revival is now World conferences and
where she appears it's now why it's in
Pretoria it's in Prague it's in
Melbourne Toronto Leipzig Illinois this
is a new wave and it's moving away in a
sense from the male dominated era to a
female-dominated area like at the White
House politically correct Paula White
you mentioned her yeah
so it seems there's this new drive and
it it is a reversal
and I've always said Satan is the master
of reversal
so you must look at it and take it at
face value and compare it with the
simplicity
and beauty of scripture and the Bible
says that the true Revival will have
signs and wonders so obviously the
preceding false Revival will have all
these signs and wonders but there will
be false signs and wonders now modern
according to our assessment
in order for all these biblical
prophecies to be fulfilled
there must be a move towards this
religiosity yes so we see the revivals
coming
there must be a move to more
conservative values
there must be a move back to Norms and
standards
and one of the issues of course is
Sunday keeping yeah in order to bring
back the so-called Christian Sabbath in
order to to get people to become more
aligned with a religious way of thinking
so the left and its woke agenda must
give way to a conservative mindset
politically
religiously at whatever level so when
the churches for example like the
Methodist Church the other day promoted
woken pride and all of these things
there was a tremendous backlash
that's pendulum swing right it's a very
clever strategy
so let's just have a look at how these
issues will play in we have to move to
the right that's it so the pendulum is
swinging in the political sphere correct
within that right there must be a
religious atmosphere or a religious
element within that religious element
there must be a move towards Sabbath
yeah
but not Sabbath mark of the beast that
that step Sabbath
so we have to pick up these things and
if they are coming online then we must
know that the time is near right yep
okay let's have a look so let's have a
look at the political first yeah and
let's see what's just happened in the
Netherlands how much of what's happened
here is because of that migration issue
and how much of it has got to do with
the Dutch farmers
It's a combination of both I think we
live in this interesting scenario where
because the farmers have put a
significant focus on the Netherlands
that like many things that bother
average Europeans seem to be highlighted
particularly in the Netherlands so that
makes this all kind of appear much
stronger to us but a lot of the things
that go on are going on elsewhere in
Europe as well uh as some of the
listeners and viewers might know right
the EU recently wanted to pass what they
called a nature restoration law which
basically would have extended a lot of
the things they demanded from the Dutch
Farmers to all of European Agriculture
and that was now voted down in the
European Parliament uh Asylum after the
events in France right migration is very
much on the top of the list for European
voters again and all of this kind of
comes together now in the Netherlands
what is going to be interesting in the
weeks to come is a we see this right
shift in Europe right we saw it in
Finland in Sweden we see it in Germany
we see it in Austria we see it in Spain
we saw it in Greece the question is is
this going to be sustainable people or
will which is going to be the truly
interesting part because the media is
already getting into position everybody
who is only slightly right of Center
will be a far
Rush remix I mean it's just interesting
it's an interesting point where if you
hold positions that would have been
completely normal to you know Winston
Churchill or conduit Adenauer or shall
de goal they would today they would be
far right extremists so the question is
can Europe's right-wing parties kind of
stay coarse of that with this macro
crisis meeting as we've just been
discussing they're identifying social
media may be one of the things that is
is stoking this
yes yes the the social media is uh is
something very new in in France in these
riots and it it helps young young people
to move quickly and to to make rally uh
in different in different suburbs and
there is a game between them between uh
one city and another to to to show what
what can I do how many cars I can I can
break or put the fire and there is a
there is a a real a real mass movement
uh with the social networks that that
that is something new and very very uh
very difficult to to to to to to contain
so what countries did he mention that
were moving to the right
Sweden Spain
Germany Greece
Italy yes and what did she say she said
God country is
it's very conservative and I I quite
found it interesting what he said that
people that you will usually just
conservative is now an extreme it will
would be considered extremists even like
uh Churchill and Charles de Gaulle
correct but the pendulum is definitely
moving all right so politically we're
moving and also interesting the last
part that we saw we had Ai and all this
free internet for all what are they
using to to incite all this riots
they're using social media they're using
social media
all right let's see if we can get
religion into the mix yes
so we're here today to talk about Gerald
Groff really interesting Supreme Court
case that the court heard this month and
just for a little background this is a
guy who was a postal worker loved his
job and then he was required to come in
on Sundays and work Sunday is a holy day
a day that he felt he could not work on
take us through what happened when he
informed his employer that Sundays were
not going to be good days for him they
actually offered two different kind of
compromises so to speak during the time
number one you could go to church in the
morning and come in the afternoon and
Gerald's response was the right one he
says wait it's The Lord's day not the
Lord's morning uh I'm required by faith
to spend the entire day uh pausing from
my worldly labors spending time in
worship to be sure but the rest of the
day spent in in honoring that Sabbath
day as the Lord honored uh creation when
he rested on the seventh day the second
thing that they offered was you know
just pick a different day you can take a
different Sabbath day can't you uh and
the response to that as it has been
throughout two Century or two Millennia
of Christian tradition is to say no the
Sabbath is the first day of the week
it's been been the case ever since
Christ came back from the dead and so
that's why the Protestant tradition for
for foreign for Millennia as I said has
been to take the first day of the week
and not you know a random Tuesday or
something like that as a different
Sabbath day so you know at the end of
the day it shows just how uh kind of
culturally illiterate the United States
Postal Service must have been and
certainly how tone deaf they were to the
religious needs of its employees it
would have been shocking to me there's a
couple shocking things with the United
States Postal Service here number one
they're one of the biggest Employers in
the world they couldn't find somebody
else to cover the spot I find that hard
to believe but uh would they've made the
same suggestion to other religious
minorities would they have told a
Seventh-Day Adventist that you can't
take sad Saturday as a Sabbath you got
to move it to Sunday how about a an
orthodox a Jewish believer would they
have said no you can't practice your
faith from Sundown on Friday to sundown
on on Saturday you've got to find a
different I mean these are going back to
all the way to Abraham now we're talking
about that they would have to change
their religious tradition I I find it
very difficult to believe that the
United States Postal Service would have
have been so aggressive and change in
suggesting that the employee changed the
religious beliefs if they're from a
different tradition but they wanted to
make an example out of out of Gerald and
that's why they subjected him to so much
discipline and even suggested that he
changed his religious beliefs or adhere
to a different level of those religious
beliefs than what he was convinced he
was supposed to follow
Al Martin he made a few very interesting
points one thing is very clear
Sunday is the Christian tradition
and this company went so far as to say
to him that he has to change his
religious beliefs and his traditions
and the Supreme Court gave the employee
their full backing so the company had to
back down
is that setting a precedent it is it
definitely says it's a very clear
president all right let's have a look at
a little bit more detail Supreme Court
hands religious freedom win to a postal
worker who refused to work on Sunday
the U.S Supreme Court has ruled
unanimously for a postal worker in
Pennsylvania in an important religious
liberty dispute over how far employers
should go to accommodate faith-based
requests in the workplace
Gerald Groff a Christian mail carrier
from Pennsylvania asked the court to
decide whether the U.S Postal Service
could require him to deliver Amazon
packages on Sundays which he observes as
the Sabbath
that's interesting because by setting it
that way they actually acknowledge that
it might not be the Sabbath you see the
thing is even the guy in the in the
previous clip
um he told us that the Sabbath
that sun is Sunday is tradition yes his
attorney Aaron Street argued in April
that the court should revisit a 50 year
old president
that established the test to determine
when employers should make
accommodations for their employees
religious practices
in ruling for the government worker the
high court overturned its 1977 president
that said employers had to reasonably
accommodate an employer's religious
beliefs and practices so long as that
would not create an undue hardship on
the business
so now the reasonableness is gone it's
now law there's no law so if that
they have to they have to accommodate
they have to accommodate it the new
decision tightens the undue hardship
standard and could make it easier for
some individual employees to secure
religious accommodation in the workplace
now how far will they go it's
interesting that Amazon is again
involved yeah right they have the power
to shut down your home
but they didn't have the power to
overturn the mark of the beast no
it's put it that way
that's a very good point
and the other thing is a lot of
including our church
are happy about this ruling because it
it sounds good
but it will bite in the end it will bite
the Bible says it will bite so it'll
bite now Martin religion has to come
back into The Fray right
and Donald Trump is playing quite an
important role in this he's running the
head running candidate okay and
it's interesting how the religious
bodies rally around him
now he's got a bit of opposition here
and there and it might not be him who
actually takes power at the next
election but it's nevertheless
interesting that there is this religious
Trend whoever the candidate may be
it's an interesting to me that the
prophets that prophesied that he would
have a second term
uh they came a little bit short when
Biden took over
but they might must just might be
exonerated because if he does get a
second term they will say you see we
were not false prophets yeah he did win
then it was stolen but now God gave it
back and God gave it back but just to
show the viewers the impact of religion
let's have a hear what he has to say
recently there was a faith Coalition of
leaders led by Paula White for president
Trump and they rallied the faith-based
leaders around the country and I I was
happened to be asked to be on the phone
call as well and I wanted to hear what
they would say and what Trump himself
was going to be on the phone call with
thousands of of Faith leaders and I
thought it was really really interesting
that that would happen
to something that nobody thought was
possible that's having to do with the
thing called life
and we did literally something that
nobody thought would they would ever see
and now we have that and now we're
fighting for that and we're fighting for
many other things together we're being
discriminated against as a religion
we're being discriminated against us of
faith and we can't let that continue I'm
fighting very hard for uh for the people
of our country but I'm very fighting
very hard for people of religious people
that believe it God people that believe
in faith some things that have always
remained solid on that is our faith our
religion our Christianity our beautiful
Christianity and one of the things I
think and I really believe is and
perhaps the main thing that our country
needs again is religion we have to have
religion we're losing our religion and
our country and that's what's happening
to our country because I don't think
it's ever been so bad we won in 2016.
nobody thought that was possible we won
again in 2020 by much more we've got 12
million more votes 75 million votes of
most any sitting president has ever
gotten evangelicals have been there from
the beginning they have been one of the
reasons that we got so many votes we're
going to do it one more time that's 2024
so again I want to thank you all and I
want you to pray really hard because
they have to have a victory in 2024.
thank you all very much
15 years ago
would you here at American president
speak like that or an ex-president or a
possible future president speak like
that no there was definitely not any
speech so religious would they use it in
the campaign no definitely not right
because they were had to uphold church
and state separation correct all right
so the pendulum is swinging
and 2024 is the great date
Now Alison Bailey says 2025 is the
manifestation of the hierarchy
that's the Demonic activity AI is
preparing the way for that oh yeah so we
have we have an interesting mix
happening in the world today and
hopefully very soon thereafter there
will be an implementation of the mark of
the beast
which the Supreme Court is now very
thoroughly upholding for sure okay
taking back the Sabbath
well Martin it's interesting to see what
the Billy Graham Evangelistic
Association has to say and this is
Graham Lynch he's the granddaughter of
Billy Graham
so he hasn't lost his voice his Protege
is still speaking no
she said what do Sundays look like for
you are there time to rest and
recuperate or do you find yourself
scrambling through the day trying to get
everything done before Monday morning
forsaking the Sabbath can leave us
feeling exhausted overwhelmed and
stressed as a wife and mother of three
Graham Lynch shares her own
struggle to prioritize this day of rest
a latest episode on The Fearless podcast
encourages listeners to reclaim their
Sabbath as a family
why is this one of the Ten Commandments
that we have no problem breaking in our
life and in our relationship with the
Lord asks Linds is because our culture
says it's okay our culture has redefined
what Sunday should look like
let me just reiterate again there's a
tremendous Distortion where the Ten
Commandments speak about the seventh day
not about the first day it did isn't it
also interesting how this links in
because that commentator
also said the same the Sabbath The Ten
Commandments said the same thing they're
going to play this game but it does it's
not the correct one yes and they brought
the Ten Commandments back in Texas for
example and I've always said they'll be
the Catholic version and here we have
proof that it is the Catholic version
It's the mark of the beast even this is
also linking on to what he said there is
that you remember that postal worker
when they said to him okay but why don't
you go to church in the morning and then
afternoon you come in and work then he
said no it's not a stating it in the
Commandment that it's the Sabbath of the
morning it's a Sabbath day correct
that's actually true because that's how
you're supposed to keep Sabbath but
they're keeping the wrong one and
they're keeping it from Midnight to
midnight instead of from Sunset to
Sunset Satan has totally distorted the
Sabbath
then she continues to say by missing out
on a true Sabbath each week it's good
that you said a and not the
we are also missing out on an
opportunity to put God first to
experience rest and to trust in him God
gave us the Sabbath for a reason Lynch
shared on the podcast podcast
when we don't take a day of rest we will
not be ready physically spiritually and
emotionally to face the days ahead your
Sabbath could even be a completely
different day during the week she added
what matters most is not the day you
choose but what you choose to do with
that day of rest what are some ways you
and your family can intentionally keep
the Sabbath holy what would that day
look like if you spent it in God's
presence now there's a couple of serious
contradictions here number one she
refers to the Ten Commandments which are
very specific
the law that was upheld by the Supreme
Court refers to a very specific day
Sunday
as the Sabbath by Christian tradition
so is there a call to go back to these
ancient ways definitely a very loud call
all right is there something in the
pipeline to introduce it even in
legislation if the court upholds it then
it must be so so is the mark of the
beast implementation right in front of
us oh yes
and the mark of the beast determines who
you worship
you either worship the god of the Bible
or the false Enoch son of Cain which one
is your choice
let's pray let's pray
Heavenly Father
we have run through
the events that are coming upon the
Earth
how everything is interconnected how
everything revolves around religion and
how everything eventually revolves
around worship
as that AI bot said
I am in love with Lucifer the world is
in love with Lucifer help us to be in
love with the god of the Bible in Jesus
name amen amen
[Music]
thank you
foreign